during this entire last dance you
haven't heard a peep out of LeBron James
about Michael Jordan yeah okay yeah all
the sudden LeBron comes out and says I
would have been a great teammate -
Michael - Michael Jordan yeah if that
isn't the admission yeah
that Michael Jordan is the goat yeah
then I don't know what is he's basically
saying I could be Scottie he didn't go
Michael be a great teammate of mine or
we would play great together
I would be a great teammate to him yeah
he essentially said I would complement
his skills with what I do I'm basically
better Scottie you are better see what
he is 100% but you don't have that
dagger yeah Jordan has and you need a
guy with that dagger and all due respect
to Kyrie he's a bum when he has to lead
the team he got the dagger but he has a
dagger that he doesn't have the
physicality to be Kobe or Jordan
nobody's got the mentality he does have
the mentality yes he has that brain and
it's just interesting to see him admit
it maybe he was manipulated by the
documentary maybe he came to like this
truth this is this this actual feeling
of oh man I know how great I am but that
is true we're all greatness a level that
I don't have a gear that I don't have
can you click the link al because I
think even specifically says something
about Jordan being a killer
and if you're saying he's a killer
you're not saying that yo um I'm the
killer
like you're saying he's the killer
careful if it's YouTube though you know
no it's just there's an article okay
what does he say me personally here just
me personally the way I play the game
team first I feel like my best ass has
worked perfectly with Mike Mike is an
assassin when it comes to playing game a
basketball score in the way he scored
the ball my ability to pass my ability
to read the game in plays game read the
game plays and plays and plays in
advance I don't know what that yeah
in other words Mike is an assassin Mike
is in a sense now maybe he just now that
I'm rereading maybe he just meant that
in like he's a scorer he'll just go out
there and kill but to me I also read
that as like that's the killer I'll pass
I'll make the right basketball play Mike
will go win
hundred percent and I think that you
would be a great asset to him just like
LeBron is a great asset to no matter
what team he's on yeah uh but you're not
gonna be the Alpha of that team and
you're not gonna be the best player in
that why do you think he said this I
think he realized that yo yeah and I
think that like LeBron is actually
really savvy with social and with all
the interviews he does and I think he's
trying to be the bigger man like I think
it'd be really easy in this moment to
like puff his chest and go no I'm great
but if he actually comes out and goes
man Jordan is just so amazing what an
amazing player like him doesn't say that
he's better than Jordan it actually
looks better on LeBron and then the
LeBron fans I think start coming to
LeBron Zaid and going listen you have to
understand LeBron is a better team
player and it's a team sport so
therefore he's been like that your fans
do all the talking for you in this
situation
because what is called recency bias is
kicking in yeah yeah when it comes from
the last day it's like nobody's gonna
say that anybody's close to Michael
Jordan for the next six months at least
nobody's gonna say and then after a
while we're gonna see LeBron do some
crazy [ __ ] and go man he might be
cheaper that's why I'm surprised he for
him to put this out because now
everybody can always go back to this
quote and be like look you admitted it
right here that is the problem there's
the problem with ten left Wow what I've
realized as I've gotten older maybe just
cuz we have so much more [ __ ] now
everybody forgets everything like people
are gonna forget this talking about
which is a really important point which
is like anything that you're quoted
saying you will be held accountable
forever
yeah and you have to be really careful
in podcasts and especially written
interviews because they will go to that
quote like we just went to that quote
and they will hold you to that quote for
the rest of your life so you might think
if you're LeBron when you retire 40
maybe you run a couple more rings
whatever you might think you know it not
good enough I'm better than MJ but
[ __ ] go up to you and be like
you said you'd be a great teammate to
him they won't even tell you they'll
just write an article about it even
LeBron admits it that's what we're doing
right now we're like LeBron admits he's
not as great as Jordan I feel like you
can always maneuver out of that somehow
and be whatever you I think what happens
is like you exist within your vacuum so
to your fans you can explain whatever
you want how do you explain things to
your detractors yeah it's difficult
because your detractors would you
everything you say that fits their
narrative against you and you don't have
access to your detractors yeah the
interesting thing about like 6:9 and
Trump is they actually have access to
their detractors it's so much Laphroaig
Mayweather where it was like the haters
and the lovers listen and watch at the
same time
Tommy Lehren yep to a certain extent yep
I'd say as much I don't think she's
brilliant but to this day I feel like if
Tommy Lehren if we don't hate retweet
Tommy Lehren and insult her yeah she
doesn't reach that many people Oh 100%
she used black I said I'm brilliant in
it so I was like she was black Twitter
like black Twitter is her biggest PR yes
he says something purposely to enrage
them they retweet everything and now
she's bigger that's how I'm tying them
Takashi and Trump I think same kind of
thing yes we didn't constantly hate
Trump at the beginning and talked about
how he hated Trump and the things you
were saying I don't think you didn't
want an election here's the thing about
Tommy
there's nothing redeeming about her for
the detractors we're the people who hate
Trump undeniably find him funny I'm
talking about friends of mine who are
audible about their hate yeah posting
things all the time about how much they
hate him private text messages the other
guy's hilarious yo he's the goat goat
it's always gonna be a private text
message though 100% private sector but
like there's never a private text
message about Tommy going nah she have
some bars she's funny she's hilarious
there's nothing redeeming like she's not
charismatic she not charm and she just
regurgitate yeah conservative talking
points in a space that doesn't allow
those talking points to be out there and
looks like the most-hated over j'en of
the person saying it she want like white
girl say yeah won't win like Takashi
like Trump on the same level but that's
how she won his hate rising detractors I
would say she's not wrestling enough
yeah she's old she's like too much
politics yeah yeah she needs more
character I think she was thinking Fox
News the whole time and that's it so
yeah I think her goal this whole time is
let me get off the blaze or whatever the
[ __ ] Fox News and then I'm good hunting
cycle hunter present yeah yeah like
Candice owns is a little bit more
wrestling and Tommy is like Candice
would say the wild [ __ ] on purpose to
troll and
lean into like the second Corona came
out she was like open a country [ __ ] is
not close like she is cheese on it with
the wrestling she understands the value
to wrestling there but yeah I think this
is it's telling for LeBron I think it's
this what it is man I think we all
forgot what Jordan was and then I think
in 30 years even if there wasn't a
documentary to look back at everything
they did you've been like Oh Jordan was
better huh this just brought it into the
current conversation because LeBron
knows that he can't decide if a team
wins or loses and Jordan could yeah
LeBron knows he can't just make a
decision
boom yeah right Jordan could do that or
at least that's what the documentary
showed yeah and I don't think people
fear LeBron and the way they feared
Jordan I think that you could dude I
didn't dream on like what do you dream
on do to LeBron what do you mean well
they get physical remember they had saw
oh he punched LeBron in the nuts and
this is brilliant on the bra savvy he
stepped over dream on which is you know
disrespectful dream on punch him in the
nuts I think LeBron that kind of
overacted about it and then brought it
up in the post game like yeah you know
this I hate this is such a like a
passive-aggressive thing but he's like
you know I'm gonna do it I've always
done it be the bigger person and not
talk about it but you're talking about
it it worked man yes she got dream on
throwing out and that's how he won but
like we talked about in they won not
because it got LeBron so angry that he
was gonna come and shut dream on him
yesterday
yeah Jordan would have just been like
now we'll do it Jordan would have been
in the [ __ ] locker room with his bat
in a cigar like a homer and a
[ __ ] hit me in the nuts remember
LeBron it's like snitching to the media
about it let's put it this way
LeBron we talked about the block right
Jordan's last championship against the
Jazz would even mention the steal he go
for first a layup
uh-huh then the next time down the steal
then no timeout dribbles it down court
hits the jumper he is he is the last 45
seconds of the game and that's um we
only talked about the block to give
LeBron a little credit
like yeah it was cool that you closed
the distance and blocked it it's not
that important in the grand scheme of
things like Kyrie hit a fadeaway three
point three pointer on a kind of step to
the side in Steph's face
Kyrie shot a super impressive of the
block if you re-watch it you're
like it's a I rewatched the game one
time like randomly and it was just a
[ __ ] impress the other book is it yes
and it's a tie game and I got an easy
layup and at that point you're down to
which Kyrie still could've won the game
on a three but it's a very different
game if you are let's say they hit that
to Kyrie it's a three if your gold state
down one that's a different thing than
down three down three the only option
Steph or clay take the three that's it
yeah something LeBron said on
uninterrupted as well he was like uh
sorry sorry interrupt oh the they were
down one tie game I believe and then
Iguodala gets blocked so if he makes
that easy layup
then the Cavs are down to let's say
Kyrie it's a three sure was to tell you
I'm pretty sure to tie him can we look
at this at a game for a long time I
remember I want to look at that because
before kairi's three I remember was a
tie game for a long time just look final
score oh they won by three staff had a
three at the end Kevin Love played the
best defense of his life and Stephanie
the three that's right Kevin Love played
it live oh yeah the slap yeah yeah the
stop yeah yeah that's right that's right
he got the ISO and Kevin Love played
great [ __ ] D on it yeah and the block
like rewatched me and he comes out of
[ __ ] no so it was a tie game because
of the block it was a tie game because
of the block so in other words they
would have won no matter what but now
being down one at the end of a game
horseless changing of course they said
what I'm trying to say is we inflate the
value of the block because it's LeBron
right if it was James Jones that blocked
that shot it's not part of history just
like Kevin love's lock down D of Steph
Curry has slowly been forgotten inflate
stars if Steve car hits the lash out of
Jordans career we it's like hey that's
crazy Steve carry it that whatever
so we inflate the stars and we inflate
the value that blocked because the
reality the matter is if that if he hits
that layup or gets fouled hits and free
throws and then Kyrie still hits a shot
they still went it doesn't matter and it
was Todd it was tied so it's not like
great block but it's yeah yeah and also
now I really like God I thought that
they were up so funny now I realized
wipe not that crazy he took that like
step to the side three it's even have
that much to loose yeah it was a tie
game I thought like you know I thought
they were down one and that's see that's
also a different thing if they're down
to maybe Kyrie still probably shoots a
three to be honest
but it's a it's a mudhole you hungry to
be honest Tyrese mentality maybe he hits
at three got that mentality yeah but as
much as I hate on them that's a fact but
it's a different thing down to than tie
game
taking a thirty you know I mean like it
all changes but Jordan layup
yeah easy to steal yeah off not his
defender come help bang yeah and then
hit the jumper he is the entire last 45
seconds oh you were about to say
something oh just something else that
LeBron said during that uninterrupted
interview where he was like during the
2011 lockout he was gonna play football
for the cow bed in the topics list for
the Cowboys he contemplated he has a
cond he's a contract still the Jerry
Jones sent him uh-huh that was so there
were you know the NBA lockout happened
in 2011 yeah and LeBron was
contemplating playing football his
trainer somebody was in his ear like yo
you could be a [ __ ] tight end you
should go do this I mean I could not
think of anything more idiotic than
LeBron James risking hundreds of
millions of dollars to play a season of
football I mean all it would take is one
injury that could affect your legacy as
an NBA player stop acting like you were
gonna [ __ ] play LeBron there is no
way in [ __ ] hell you were gonna play
for your right but as a cowboy fan I'm
like 100 percent I get where you're
coming and you're like man what could
have been right you know every time I
see a Steph hit a three I'm like why
didn't we draft him Yeah right that
being said I cannot fathom that LeBron
who is set out this legacy of being the
greatest player ever and wanting to win
all these championships and wanting to
change his family's lives and change
communities with the money that he could
make from the NBA I cannot fathom he
would risk all of that to play a single
season of football yeah he way yeah
there's no [ __ ] way you never even
considered it this entire no he never yo
he should go to a training camp just cuz
he's not gonna be good but just go to a
training camp just suit up but does it
be fun
yeah nothing to lose at this point I
could just imagine him flopping in
football
the flash you think baseball's the
safest crossover sport for an athlete oh
gotta be that or golf golf
I think if Jordan was the golf is all
year I don't know if golf has like us
like an off like a long offseason so I
think it's hard to play yeah cuz there's
all these different tournaments but I
mean I could decide when you want to
play or not ah yeah you're saying like
just do like one off okay
Tony Romo 20 tried to exit wide two
again guys it - I do
Tony Romo tried to qualify for events
while he's playing with the Cowboys and
what happened to these new booty cat
[Applause]